here the Richard Holden the transport
Minister how are you very well thank you
it's good to see you thanks for coming
in
um talk to me if you would please about
bosses two pounds you can go uh very far
or on two pounds on a bus if there is a
bus because lots of them have been
canceled no that's true so what we've uh
I think you're right to highlight
reliability and one of the things that
we've been really targeting since the
end of the um pandemic is trying to get
that reliability back it's much better
than it was we've still got further to
go but things like driver shortages are
being tackled and this package is a
really big package it takes the total
support we've given since 2020 to the
sector to around three and a half
billion pounds it's another 500 million
pounds today and that's going to provide
real certainty in two ways first of all
we're going to provide 150 million
pounds a year for the next two years the
bus sector to enable them to support
those service levels as they are now and
also we're providing extra cash for
households and with a two pound bus cap
all the way through to the 31st of
October this is a second extension we've
done and then there'll be a two pound 50
cap from the first of November all the
way through to November next year as
well because I know from my own
constituency but also right across the
country how pressed people are when it
comes to cost of living uh particularly
bus users who are often people in lower
paid work and I want to do what we can
to help but one in ten bus routes
accident of the last year minister no
exactly and I don't want to see any more
full that's exactly why we've put the
are you going to get them back up again
well that's why we put the cash in there
at the moment over the next two years
we've also put a lot over a billion
pounds into bus service improvement
plans across the country for some of our
biggest areas one of those was signed
off just a couple of weeks ago for the
northeast of England which is really
targeting some of those routes as well
so yes we've seen some issues and but
unlike the SMP in Scotland or laboring
Wales you know we've had this bus fare
cap which I think is should really help
people particularly low paid workers who
need to move a Distance on the bus every
day
um really helping save their costs on
that and but also we're putting this
extra cash in and I've announced that
for the next two years to give bus
companies certainty because at the
moment they've been having to wait three
months to three months to see exactly
what cash they'll be getting okay talk
to me about the renters Reform Bill if
you would please Minister a lot of my
younger members of my team very
exercised by this particular story it
comes with more powers for landlords to
evict people for anti-social behavior
um what would anti-social behavior mean
well can I just take an issue from my
own constituency what I often get is
people complaining about tenants living
next door who've come in causing real
problems in their area or you know
persistent uh really late night noise
all that sort of thing that's what we
need to stop and because it's not about
the landlords it's about the other
tenants who might live in the same block
or in the same street as somebody else
and I think on the other side what we
are
is anti-social Behavior well anti-social
Behavior does be decided either by the
police or the courts right that's the
that's where the dogs barking that's
what it is social behavior but if it's
Relentless and all night then definitely
particularly in some of my poor
communities and there are real issues
with antisocial behavior from some
tenants on the other side we do need to
protect tenants rights and the guy
didn't own my own home until I was in my
mid-30s you know I rented all the way
through and there's a variety of
landlords some good uh some not so good
but I think ending no fault eviction is
a sensible thing to do allowing people
uh to have pets is a good thing to do as
well and also you know some of those
restrictions around people you know not
be able to have children in certain
properties and things like that I think
also being removed I think we've got it
we're going to strike the right balance
here between ensuring that renters can
have somewhere safe and secure to live
and have a normal life there and also
ensure that that some Rogue tenants
don't disrupt entire neighborhoods with
people as well okay so didn't have your
own property till you were in your
mid-30s they didn't buy my first home
now I don't like I say you're in your
mid-30s now
talk to me about the suggestion in the
paper this morning that refugees could
be moved into the private renting sector
and more people could be put into
smaller spaces to try to solve the
issues that you've got with with
migrants well one of the issues that we
saw over the last few years is around
Hotel accommodation and even with some
of the refugees we've brought in from
places like
um Syria we've seen people of
Afghanistan stuck in hotel accommodation
for far too long and getting them out of
that accommodation into longer term
accommodation which means that actually
if you know talking about families for
example kids can put down routes in
schools and things like that that's got
to be the right way forwards all we want
to see is people and it's burst out into
the country and who've got that proper
Refugee status who we've brought here in
the right way and so that they can
actually set down routes I've had some
people from these Syrian refugee scheme
and moved into my own constituency who
had been in temporary accommodation what
we want to see is if we do have people
who've come through those proper schemes
that they're able to set up lives here
in the UK and support their families as
well what are you going to do to make
sure that um some landlords don't Pile
in as many refugees as they possibly can
into a property well I mean so well
we've already got um safeguards around
what's known as um houses of multiple
occupancy yes um which are so it means
it's illegal for you to have more than
certain numbers of people in in
properties but according to the paper
this morning that's going to be relaxed
somewhat well I think one of the things
the biggest concerns that everybody has
at the moment is large numbers of
refugees and being kept in some areas
for a very long periods of time just
like we've seen with the illegal
migrants who are also trying to deal
with what we want to do is get these
people if they're genuine refugees
dispersed out into the country as
quickly as possible so they can set down
routes you know enter employment and
ensure their kids can get into school
and if they're not legal then we want to
get them into these other facilities
that we're looking at now like the
barges or the former energy basis so
that they can be processed as quickly as
possible as well I think it's sensible
to not have people costing millions of
pounds a day in hotel accommodation
which also can be a real issue for when
they're put into small towns often with
the only accommodation available because
you can understand from the other side
of the people who might own the hotel so
it's guaranteed income we need to move
away from that to something which
ensures that those are the genuine right
to be here and are looked after and part
of the community and those who aren't
get moved on yeah but my question was
how are you going to make sure that we
don't see lots of refugees or migrants
piled into small spaces well we do have
rules around housing multiple occupancy
we'll have to see exactly what the
proposals being brought forwards are but
those are pretty strict at the moment
um I'm not exactly sure what the HMO
relaxations might be but they are very
stringent at the moment and I wouldn't
like to see them move too far in any
area just before I let you go
um
the shortest serving prime minister ever
causing trouble for the British
government some might say in Taiwan
what's he up to well I mean Liz is back
bencher now I used to be back bencher
not that long ago she can go around and
so she likes look it's not helpful
though is it well I I think I think
we've all moved on from that era now
um I think what we want to see is what
we've got in Rishi which is a prime
minister who's concentrated on what the
people's priorities are we should be
taking any notice of her well that's
well I would just say let's concentrate
what we've got now right you know the
Prime Minister has been focused over the
winter in paying basically half of
people's energy bills because we know
the Russian invasion of Ukraine has sent
everything through the roof is paid for
that with windfall tax on energy
companies on the other side as well you
know it's all of that support he put in
through covid like with furlough now
with our announcement today on things
like buses yeah we're trying to keep
inflation down we're really hit yeah but
we've got priorities yeah so shut up I
just say you know we should all be team
players and at the moment we've got the
biggest disability for my constituents
and I think for the British people is
getting prices under control
um so I'm getting economic growth back
so you know those are the things we
should be doing that's what the Prime
Minister will be doing uh this week in
Japan we are out of time ministry it's
good to see you as always